[Musique]
alors aujourd'hui je vais vous faire une
recette de cookies aux noisettes et aux
pépites de chocolat avec un petit peu de
pub est accablante pour cela environ 10
ingrédients pour faire à peu près neuf
coups qui on commence par la farine donc
l' avantage de la farine d'orge monde et
ses caves à un indice glycémique de
trenque dire qu'avoir une ferme qui va
plomber la glycémie
alors que la farine de blé blanche en
comparaison à un indice glycémique de 75
ensuite il faut mettre la poudre
d'amandes le son d'avoine qui apporte
beaucoup de fibres et fait baisser la
glycémie et enfants le bicarbonate
mélanger le tout bravo du lait végétal
gauche choisit les de cajou mais ça peut
être
du lait d'amande lait d'avoine ensuite
mettre le sirop d'agavé qui est un
fructose et remplace le sucre blanc en
général dans une recette classique de
coûts qui ont peu à voir près 100 g de
sucre
moi je les 30 grammes là dessus la gav
en temps normal on devrait plutôt un
mètre 70 g si on voulait avoir une
équivalence de sucre identique finale
fonte 30 grammes c'est largement
suffisant
[Musique]
ce troisième étape le gras mettre
l'huile de coco et la purée de
cacahuètes la grèce en indice glycémique
2 0 il faut tout de même faire attention
dernier ingrédient donc je mette des
pépites de chocolat noir
donc j'ai pris
du chocolat noir avons trouvé de 60 % de
cacao également faudra mettre du 70 le
chocolat contient du sucre est
mentalement il ne reste plus qu'à former
des blocs d'une épaisseur d'un
centimètre et les mettre au four à 180°
pendant 12 minutes et voilà des cookies
avec trois fois moins de sucre qu'un
cookie classique
[Musique]